let's attempt another surface integral
and i've changed the notation a little
bit instead of writing the surface as a
capital sigma i've written it as a
capital s instead of writing d lowercase
sigma i wrote d uppercase s but this is
still a surface integral of the function
y and the surface we care about is x
plus y squared minus z is equal to zero
x between zero and one y between zero
and two now this one might be a little
bit more straightforward than the last
one or at least i hope it's a little bit
more straightforward because because we
can explicitly define z in terms of x
and y and actually we could even
explicitly define x in terms of y and z
but i'll do it the other way it's a
little bit easier for me to visualize so
if you add z to both sides of this
equation right over here you get x plus
y squared is equal to z or z is equal to
x plus y squared and this is actually
pretty straightforward to v this surface
is pretty easy to visualize or we can
give our best attempt at visualizing it
so if that is
that is our z-axis
and that is
our x-axis
the y-axis we care about the region x
between zero and one so maybe this is x
equals one and y between zero and two so
let's say this is one this is two and
the y area so this is we essentially
care about the surface over this over
this region of the x y plane and then we
can think about what the surface
actually looks like this isn't the
surface this is just kind of the range
of x and y's that we actually care about
and so let's think about the surface
when x and y are zero z is zero so we're
going to be sitting let me do this in a
in green z is going to be right over
there and now as y increases as or if we
if when x is equal to 0 for just talking
about the z y plane z is going to be
equal to y squared so z is going to be
equal to y squared so this might be z is
equal to 4 this is z is equal to 2
1 3. so z is going to do something like
this it's going to look it's going to be
a parabola in the z y plane it's going
to look something
something like that
now when y is equal to 0 z is just equal
to x
so as x goes to 1 z will also go to 1.
so z
will go like this the scales of of the
axes aren't they're not drawn to scale
the z is a little bit more compressed
than the x or y the way i've drawn them
and then from this point right over here
you add the y squared and so you get
something that looks something that
looks so this is
this is this point there and then
this point when y is equal to 2 and x is
equal to 1 if z is equal to 5. it's
going to look something like this
something like this and then you're
going to have the straight line like
that and this point is right over there
and this surface is the surface that we
are going to take
or the surface over which we're going to
we're going to we're going to evaluate
the surface integral of the function y
and so one way you could think about it
y could be maybe the mass density of
this surface and so when you when you
multiply y times each ds you're
essentially figuring out the mass of
that little chunk
and and then you're figuring out the
mass of this entire surface and so one
way you can imagine as we go more and
more in that direction as y is
increasing this thing is getting more
and more dense so this part
this part of the surface is more dense
is more dense than as y becomes lower
and lower and then that would actually
give us the mass but that out of the way
let's actually evaluate it and so as you
know the first step is to figure out a
parameterization and it should be pretty
straightforward because we can write z
explicitly in terms of x and y and so we
can actually use x and y as the actual
parameters or if we want to just
substitute it with different parameters
we could but let me so let's just write
let me do that so let me just write x is
equal to
x is equal to and then the spirit of
using different notation instead of
using s and t i'll use u and v
x is equal to u let's say y is equal to
v
and then z is going to be equal to
u
plus
v squared and so our surface written as
a as a vector position function or
position vector function our surface
we can write it as r which is going to
be a function of u and v
and it's going to be equal to u
i
plus v
plus v j
plus
u plus v squared
u plus v squared k
and then u is going to be between 0 and
1 because x is just equal to u or u is
equal to x so u is going to be equal to
is going to be between 0 and 1 and then
v is going to be
v is going to be between 0 and 2. i'm
going to leave you there in the next
video we'll actually set up the surface
integral now that we have the
parameterization done